[Musique]
l'auteur de 10,31 se lève à 5 heures
tous les matins il n'a pas le choix il
doit livrer la marchandise 160 pages par
semaine si une semaine que tu vas porter
sans toit sans ambages battu repose
quant à baguettes sont la semaine
d'après on finit toujours par y arriver
donc c'est la semaine les dionne
consacrent en moyenne 12 heures par jour
pour arriver à écrire au total 120
épisodes par saison
bonsoir pour le faire
je suis avant tout la vie de l'auteur
gravitent autour du district 31,7 habite
toujours ça on s'en remet en famille à
la maison je veux juste travailler c'est
longue traversée du désert subi dans un
univers pis
j'écris j'écris jeunes effectuent ce
cépage pour malheureux james auger
raconte des histoires pour être vraiment
dans sa bulle le dionne à ses habitudes
il allume une chandelle
il se met de la musique l'actualité
l'inspirent
mais ce n'est pas tout j'ai beaucoup
d'amis qui ont accueilli y est passé par
terre au sein des compagnies si j'ai
moi-même été attaché politique j'ai bon
c'est des environnements que je connais
bien district en p1 est une série oz
intrigue complexe et pour que rien
n'échappe à les dionne sa conjointe
révise ses textes le contrôle de qualité
c'est moi je me suis derrière que tous
les petits détails que tout colle bien à
l'histoire qu'on n'oublie rien par les
uns et des trucs qui m'accroche je me
disais ça me semble que spotlight ça me
qu'on devrait la borie plus notre vie
est vraiment
en fonction des districts 31 honnêtement
si je n'étais pas impliqué dans le
projet je pense que ça a été dur sur le
couple parce que c'est beaucoup beaucoup
de travail
mais comme plus d'un million de
personnes le soir le dieu ne manque pas
un épisode de district 31
je crains tu te critiquent mon écriture
oubliant pas des fois je trouve que
cheikh mali comme et think tanks à cent
à l'heure et des éternels insatisfaits
avant d'aller au lit le dionne retourne
à sa table d'écriture et le lendemain
tout est à recommencer ici julie
jocelyne boudreault radio canada
montréal